[Musique]
je connais ma fille elle a jamais été
aussi heureuse je suis dit je l' ai pas
touché je suis fidèle taper chaud hein
mais non je crois que je suis la pêche
utap les choses ça s'est creusé la bombe
a refusé que la plupart des hommes sur
vous soyez là pour lui dire adieu à dieu
parce que vous ne verrez plus jamais
s'en remettre ensemble on est une
famille
ils vont parler à garance alors et je
lui parle il faut mettre les points sur
les i
pour moi bonjour série cet engouement le
conseiller non ça c'est pas possible
mais c'est toi qui est pas possible on
vous pas toute sa vie en l'air à cause
d'un coup de pub
qu'est-ce que vous avez pas compris dans
la phrase il ne faut plus jamais revoir
surtout le crime n'a pas fait su par un
détective quand même si les taux sont
dutronc c'est un homme brisé
ceux qui pleurent tout le temps pas là
on vient ternir d'inspection ya des
trucs que jamais faire avec quelqu'un
dont on ne prononce plus le nom mais
voilà aujourd'hui je suis obligé de
faire tout seul
[Musique]
telenor temps le pâté de maisons
t'arrête pas sinon on est mort moi ça va
pas du tailleur avec pissos
qu'est ce que vous faites un tour dans
le quartier comme ça papa derrière la
caméra en angleterre on l'avait jamais
fait et que ça faisait plaisir à tous
[Musique]
ok tu veux que je te dise on n'arrive
pas à couper le cordon voilà c'est tout
on n'est pas des machines bon sens
m